hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his essay bartleby or the formula in
which
he's discussing herman melville's famous
short story bartleby the scrivener the
formula
being bartleby's statement i would
prefer
not to jill duluz is going to take what
might appear to be just
a digression into talking about
american pragmatism and he's doing it in
kind of a strange
way in which he's bringing together
literature
and philosophy and he's not actually
referencing the great you know we could
call them the big three of american
pragmatism
uh purse james dewey there's plenty of
others
as well but you know we see this mostly
as a like a late 19th century
early 20th century emerging
movement instead he's going to talk
about the transcendentalists he's going
to talk about literature
he's going to bring up more literary
figures than philosophical figures
but there is a philosophical drive
to this he's saying that pragmatism is
something distinctively american
but not quite in the way that it has
been
formulated or figured and he's going to
say something
really quite astounding towards the end
of this discussion where he's going to
say
the hero of pragmatism
is not the successful businessman and
it's not even like death of a salesman
businessman right the pseudo-successful
businessman
it's bartleby bartleby the scrivener
and daisy miller pure and isabelle the
brother and sister
so how can this be well
de luz makes something very particular
out of pragmatism and the place to begin
is where he talks about the messianism
of the 19th century
having two heads and he's going to
mention these two heads
at the beginning of this section and
towards the end he
he brings up this really interesting
passage
coming from red burn you cannot spill a
drop of american blood without spilling
the blood
of the whole world be englishman
frenchman
german dana scott the european who
scoffs at an american
calls his own brother raqqa and stands
in danger of the judgment there's a
reference of course to
the sermon on the mount we are not a
narrow tribe of men
with a bigoted hebrew nationality whose
blood has been debased in the attempt to
ennoble it
by maintaining an exclusive succession
amongst ourselves
we are not a nation so much as a world
for unless we may claim
all the world for our sire like
melchizedek we are without father
or mother we are the heirs of all time
and with all nations we divide our
inheritance now this is a very
eurocentric
point of view that ignores as alexis de
tocqueville pointed out
the horrible injustices done to
two particulars that's hopeville called
them races
black and red in democracy in america so
the lose could have
you know gone in a somewhat different
way with this but instead he's focusing
on what
melville is making of this and duluz
then says
the picture of the 19th century
proletarian looks like this
the advent of the communist man
or the society of comrades
the future soviet being without property
family or nation
has no determination than that of being
man
homo tantum human being as such but this
is
also the picture of the american
executed by other means and the traits
of the former
often intermingle with or are
superimposed over those of the latter
america now notice what deleuze tells us
about america in this sense
america sought to create a revolution
whose strength would lie in a universal
immigrant immigration emmy greys of the
world
just as bolshevik russia would seek to
make a revolution whose strength would
lie in a universal
proletari proletarization proletarians
of the world
the two forms of the class struggle so
he says the messianism
of the 19th century has two heads and is
expressed no
less notice the term he uses here in
american pragmatism
than in the ultimately russian form of
socialism he's saying this is where the
messianism of the 19th century
ultimately
takes form and it's going to take a form
that doesn't
entirely succeed in the case of the
russians anymore
than of the americans but there's
something
new coming on the scene he talks about
these associations of people without
fathers you know the loss or
disruption of paternal authority which
could be associated with the
european or with the british way of
looking at things he goes on and he
tells us
pragmatism is misunderstood when it is
seen as a summary philosophical theory
fabricated by americans and this is
actually quite true
it's not a uniquely american thing
we know that pragmatism for example
maurice blondell a great french writer
of the 19th century and early 20th
century
was perfectly willing to have his work
called pragmatism
until he found out what william james
meant by it after letting william james
his oxy in 1993
pragmatism took root in other places
other than just the united states
but that's not what duluth is talking
about here what he's saying
is that the ways in which we typically
represent pragmatism
as a uniquely philosophical movement
ignores what pragmatism is which is
something much
broader and rascinated within
life itself but also within other fields
like
literature and he goes on and he says
we understand the novelty of american
thought when we see pragmatism
as a drive an attempt
a project so what is it an attempt to
change the world to transform the world
to think a new world
or a new man insofar as they
create themselves and he says
western philosophy was the skull or the
paternal spirit that realized itself in
the world as totality
and an annoying subject as proprietor
is it against western philosophy that
melville not only doesn't talk about
james or dewey or purse
melville that melville directs his
insult metaphysical
villain and he says a contemporary of
american transcendentalism
emerson thoreau melville is already
sketching out the traits of the
pragmatism
that will be its continuation so this is
very interesting because
what the luz is seeing here is that we
don't have a
uh american philosophy of well first
there was
you know the puritans and then jonathan
edwards and the american renaissance
with
the turn to political and then we have
the transcendentalists
and then we have you know these people
then we have the
pragmatists as a successive waves of
theorization the transcendentalists are
already
prefiguring the pragmatist motif
according to
the luz and i think he's actually quite
correct there
there's there are continuities that he's
picking out and these are continuities
where dividing things up into philosophy
over here
and literature over here is rather fake
and abstract and goes against what
pragmatism
itself has to contribute
he says you know melville is sketching
out pragmatism
that will be the continuation of uh
transcendentalism
what is this affirming a world in
process an archipelago as he's gonna say
not a puzzle whose pieces fitted
together would constitute a whole
and that's the way that a lot of
systematization in
european philosophy was done we just got
to figure out how everything fits into
it you know we're going to complete the
system of german idealism right
well that's not what pragmatism and
that's not what these distinctively
american
ways of going about things try to do and
he says
rather a wall of loose uncemented stones
where every element has a value
in itself but also in relation to others
isolated and floating relations
islands and straits immobile points
insinuous
lines for truth always has jagged edges
not a skull but the vertebral vertebral
column
a spinal cord not a uniform piece of
clothing but a harlequin's coat
an infinite patchwork with multiple with
with
multiple joinings he says this is the
american
invention par excellence the patchwork
and you can if you know much of deluge
you can recognize a good bit of what
deleuze
is trying to do in his own philosophy
and what he likes in this
description of you know truthers jagged
edges a world and process and
archipelago
of relations and he's going to use this
uh metaphor of the archipelago
and what is an archipelago so it's a
set of islands that are
connected with each other not just by
you know being islands
that ultimately go down to the same land
you know underneath but also by
people sailing back and forth between
these islands maybe making bridges
between them
so this is a different way of
understanding
the world he says it was necessary
also for so that's the world it's also
necessary
for the knowing subject the sole
proprietor
right again think of german idealism or
think of british empiricism
or think of all of these you know i'm
going to start doing philosophy on my
own and build an
entire world out and then people can
read my books
this is more communal this is more
interactive and he goes on and he says
the sole proprietor gives way to a
community of explorers the brothers of
the archipelago
and they replace knowledge
with belief or rather he says with
confidence
confidence in this one and in human
beings as much as
in god so he tells us that pragmatism
this is a very interesting thing to say
and i think again a very good way to
capture what's going on in american
pragmatism
pragmatism is this double principle of
archipelago
and hope what must the community of men
consist in for truth to be possible
truth and trust and so then he tells us
here that
there's a perspectivalism that comes
with the archipelago what does that
comprise
fighting against particularities of a
certain sort not all particularity per
se
but particularities that set human
beings
against each other and again we see an
echo here
of the other kind of messianism you know
a lot of people you know they see
communism and soviets and they're like
oh
terrible they killed all sorts of people
what that ignores was the
hope that was actually there of
something like a universal brotherhood
and sisterhood
or overcoming the particularities that
separate us and put us
at each other's throats for the benefit
of those who are the elites right
that was also what was going on in
american pragmatism
with a different way of doing it so
fighting particularities but also
fighting uh the universal or the whole
the fusion of souls in the name of great
love or charity
he says well what remains then if we
take these things away
originality and not originality is
genius or you know
being unique or something like that but
being yourself
a sound that each produces he says that
it produces when it takes to the open
road or the open sea with its body when
it leads its life without seeking
salvation
when it embarks upon its incarnate
voyage without any particular aim and
then encounters
other voyagers who it recognizes
by their sound this is how lawrence who
again
deleuze takes up quite a lot uh
described the new messianism or the
democratic
contribution of american literature
against
what against the european morality of
salvation
and charity or that of law coming down
from the father figure
who's going to take care of all of us
something more of a groundswell
something coming from
us something that we tinker out and
figure out
as we go along which is again
not uniquely american but is
prototypically
american at a certain time when
pragmatism was a central motif in
american life which i would say it's
it currently is not and hasn't been for
quite a long time
he goes on and he says that
according to melville or lawrence this
brotherhood is a matter for original
souls perhaps it begins only with the
death of the father or god
but it does not derive from this death
it is a whole other
matter this requires this new
perspective and archipelago
perspectivism
that conjugates the panoramic shot and
tracking
shot we have to learn how to see things
in multiple
ways and then he says it also requires a
new community
whose members are capable of trust or
confidence
that is of a belief in themselves in the
world
and in becoming here he talks about
uh bartleby as being a sort of
representative
figure here bartleby lives cloistered in
the office and never
goes out but when the attorney suggests
new occupations to him he's not joking
when he responds there's too much
confinement
and if he's prevented from making his
voyage then the only place left for him
is prison
where he dies of civil disobedience as
through roe says
the only place where a free man can stay
with honor notice that
what deleuze is not saying here is that
america is all pragmatism pragmatism is
something that arises distinctively
within america as a response to the
other america
which is full of the people who want to
do things you know the old-fashioned way
the orderly way the father way
and so you know we can talk about
a failure that occurs here as well
so the dangers of a society without
fathers
have often been pointed out but the only
real danger
is the return of the father in this
respect it's difficult to separate the
failure of the two revolutions the
american
and the soviet the pragmatic and the
dialectical
universal immigration was no more
successful than universal
proletarization and we could talk about
all sorts of ways
in which this happens right um
he sees it says that the uh just as many
as many bolsheviks could hear the
diabolical powers knocking at the door
in 1917
what are the diabolical powers the ones
who are going to turn things back
to systems of power domination order
the old the old ways and you know
what we see unfortunately in in you know
the communist countries is a betrayal of
what they were originally aiming at and
we see this also in america
america is in some respects
insufficiently pragmatic he says
the pragmatists like melville before
them could see the masquerade that the
society of brothers
would lead to long before lawrence
melville and thoreau were diagnosing the
american evil the new cement that would
rebuild the wall paternal
authority and filthy charity
bartleby therefore lets himself die
in prison and what we have here is a
very
interesting suggestive i wouldn't
say absolutely determinative
understanding of what american
pragmatism
was and could be and
how it's connected with american
literature as well and a life
within america and within a world that
includes
other models as well
you